hello and welcome to nostalgia trip the
show where we put your nostalgia to the
test my name is Jake
I'm here with jean-luc and we're gonna
take a look at Beyond Good and Evil
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in 2003 Ubisoft released one of its most
beloved action-adventure games Beyond
Good and Evil
[Music]
the game released too overwhelming
praise in former GameSpot reviewer Jeff
Kurtzman gave it an eight point three
saying Beyond Good and Evil is a
fantastic looking game that tells its
story well despite its positive
reception the game underperformed
commercially it did get a bit of a
resurgence when the HD remaster released
in 2011 poor sales aside Beyond Good and
Evil has established itself as a cult
classic with a passionate fan base so
now I look back on Beyond Good and Evil
it is one of my most fondly remembered
games I would say I have great memories
of exploring that world playing as Jade
taking pictures of different animals are
taking in a bunch of random minigames
and I haven't really played much of it
since then I recently started playing it
again for this episode and for the most
part I was still having fun but you had
never played it so you didn't have those
previous memories you don't have the
nostalgia to sort of back up back this
up so it's curious what do you think of
beyond good people based on what your
the weekend you played it yeah it's
light I like it I it's a game that I
immediately got the sense of like why
people have a when this game is a cult
classic
[Music]
[Applause]
it's like Oh like you know there's
something about it's got that ps2 era
like charm to it there's you know I
think it's got pretty interesting like
characters in world and its kind of
trying to do so many different things
that I was like okay I understand why
this became a cult classic I think
playing it nowadays it doesn't do
anything particularly special anymore to
me in terms of like gameplay it just
sort of feels like a hodgepodge of like
different ideas that are maybe not as
realized as they could be because I felt
like there kind of I throw in like
everything against the wall but I felt
like it so it's a fun game and like it
still holds up playing it and I think if
you're interested it's worth playing
especially because you can get it like
ridiculously cheap now but I don't think
anyone playing it nowadays is probably
going to have that like insane nostalgic
love for it
the way like people who like you when it
first came out yeah I going back and
playing it like I definitely see what
you're saying I mean it has an
open-world but it's very small mm-hmm
and there's not really a lot in there
part from mini games which as you said
are all kind of half-baked right yeah I
was like the there's the racing game
which is very easy yeah there's the
shuffleboard game which totally stopped
or yes complete garbage
there's the what's it called where they
move he moves the coconuts around and
you have to guess what son oh yes I
called it's like not really a creative
minigame but no yeah it's like they're
really trying just to throw everything
at you and it's like they're not okay
nothing's bad in the game but it's just
like I don't like I'm not like oh I love
the racing like it's hard for me to
pinpoint a thing about the scheme that I
love where it's like I you know the
stealth it's it's fine the combats
pretty easy like I'd say the thing that
I would I'm probably like gravitating
them most it's just the kind of world
they built you know this like kind of
like future sci-fi like they talk about
other planets and like galaxies it's
very much like oh like there's this
whole other universe that you can like
explore but then it's very much
self-contained to this small like town
yes where you got these anthropomorphic
like it's a really interesting universe
they've set up it's interesting because
Michel and sell the creative director he
has he said in interviews that his
original idea for this game was like a
planet hopping adventure but yeah I I
think it's interesting because you can
definitely see those pieces they're like
especially when he references or where
win the game references other colonies
other other planets other systems on
these screens you can see the majority
of our correspondents they operate all
over the universe for more than 13
different systems which I really like
that sense of world building and in in a
sense to kind of counter the poor or
mediocre mini games is I think they do
add a lot to the world totally yeah it
feels like a very small story in a
larger in a larger universe which kind
of leans into like the the other thing I
like about the game which is sort of
like Jade as a character yeah she's just
sort of like she's like helping out
these orphans like at a lighthouse and
she's kind of a small-time person and
the whole the main mechanic of the game
is the camera is that like they're not
asking you like Oh Jade you're so badass
and you gotta like fight all the dudes
it's like what you do though you beat a
lot of you
do you definitely do but they're like
Jane we need you to go take these photos
which I really like that as a yeah as a
set up especially like you know there's
the whole thing is your you are co-opted
into working with this like rebellion
group to defeat this sort of like evil
government that's kind of like tricking
the population and you're like you're an
undercover journalist you have to find
photos and III think that as of like a
set up is like really neat and
interesting especially 2003 when this
game came out that was kind of unheard
of and even today I feel like there
aren't many games that I can think of
off the top of my head where your
objective is sort of to gather I don't
say gather information because a lot of
things reabsorb utt where you you have a
camera and you're supposed to film
evidence take pictures of evidence the
only gonna really comes to mind is I
would say outlast which that is a key
mechanic but I think it's super
interesting that in 2003 rather than
making a game where you are you know
supposed to save someone save the planet
like with guns with a sword whatever
your main tool is a camera that's why it
reminds me of like a ps2 era games I
when I think of that era I think of like
the variety of types of games that's all
true yes like it felt like like kind of
like big-budget studios or maybe like a
Lobo willing to experiment with like
weird ideas it reminds me of like Jack
to you know games like that where
they're just like kind of being weird
with it and you got these like sort of
open worlds like you said but like
they're not they're not quite open rolls
the way we think of like nowadays
they're like a little bit smaller one
more self github kind of like a hub yeah
exactly
[Music]
this is a game that feels like it could
have really expanded upon like being
longer having like a longer development
time it's a relatively short game yeah
and it feels like it has a lot of
ambition in the narrative and in like
the setup for the world you know we
talked about how like it's this it's
kind of setting up this like massive
galaxy but it feels self-contained and
it seems like they wanted to do a lot
more with it then they could have ended
up doing you know like the story feels a
bit rushed where it immediately goes
from you know I got to take some
pictures to like and now the citizens
they're just revolting I took a couple
and they're just immediately revolting
so it took his all it took which is I
think fine for like what the games are
going before but like I feel like
nowadays you would like expect it to
have more to it you are right how they
turn my brain to jelly are you our
contact I will say though that Jade I
think is still holds up as a character I
still think she is I think one of the
best characters that Ubisoft has made
great it was at least that I can think
of off the top of my head right now her
page I like her in page and page is
great two pages great is they're they're
both probably the best parts of the game
for me yeah I would totally agree I
definitely and I think her voice actor
is so good and I think Paige's voice
actor is very good so kundo or stuck
here no hovercraft shield optimized cut
off the power the account is empty but
then I guess that brings us to I don't
wanna say the elephant in the room but
one of the bigger things that people
have been talking about is young good
and evil - and how you can kind of stack
one up against two obviously two's not
out yet we don't know much about it but
based on what we've seen in one corner
you have a sort of light-hearted
colorful vibrant innocent game and then
in the other corner I guess it is
colorful vibrant but you have this sort
of
dark and gritty in like be more monkeys
or cussing and I kind of get it cuz I
guess I was like 12 when I played this
when it first came out but and now I'm
20-something so I I'm a little more
accustomed to that kind of that kind of
game but it's still just so much of it
seems to clash so yeah that's the thing
playing this now it's like oh I get it I
get why people were like mad about doing
good and evil too because I like I kind
of knew like okay this is deviating from
the story and you know from the gameplay
design and you know people were like oh
they did swear in the original but
having played it now I get like oh and
all that that's pretty different yes I'm
totally that's like hone and oh yeah you
know what their what their pitching even
if it is it's interesting that like it
seems like there may be trying to do
what his original vision for the game
was but like they're not offering like
they you know we again we barely see
anything about the game but they haven't
shown like there's stealth or you're
taking pictures or like what's the
narrative is about like yeah it feels
like a very different game set in that
universe and it it could be good but it
feels like it's gonna be hard to get the
people who love Beyond Good and Evil on
board because it feels like it's gonna
lack that stuff yeah also that whole
evil Jade thing that they had at the end
of the three this year there's a lot of
questions there like like nothing they
were like oh it's gonna be interesting
you're gonna find out it's like I want
to find out that doesn't make any sense
right and then they were saying it was a
prequel and now they're saying it's like
a quasi prequel yeah it makes no sense
to me
I don't know I'm looking forward to it
nonetheless but back to Beyond Good and
Evil One having playing played it for
the first time what what are your
thoughts on it like would you recommend
this game do you think it's good I think
it's a good game overall I would
definitely if you're curious about this
game I would definitely recommend it I
think you're gonna have a hard time
maybe like loving it the way someone who
like played that game you know back in
the day like loved it
I think it's just you know games have
kind of like evolved too much but I
still like a lot about the game to like
and enjoy you sorta have to put yourself
in like the mindset of a game back then
but I still think it's a good game and I
still think it's worth it especially for
me I got I don't know it this is still
true at the time when this video is out
but I was able to get it for $3 oh yeah
on the Xbox store
I played the Xbox HD Edition so for 3
bucks it was absolutely worth it but
even if it the game was like 10 bucks
I'd still say like yeah it's worth
playing I think it's worth finding a
copy of this game if you're interested
in it at all
especially with to come now yeah I
didn't play as much as you this past
weekend but I did play a little bit
leading up to it and I I I still think
it's great once again I'm nostalgic for
it right but I definitely recommend it I
think I think what you're saying is true
though if you probably won't get the
same thing out of it as I got when I was
younger or someone who played it when
they were younger when it first came out
it's probably you can get out of it but
I still think it's probably worth your
time especially if it's three bucks
does the iris mean anything to you
listen here miss iris hey my name is
Jade and I haven't the foggiest how
we're gonna get out of here but I may be
of some assistance there so you are
double H well anyway that was Beyond
Good and Evil 2 for next week's episode
of a nostalgia trip we're gonna take a
look at half-life we're doing things a
little bit differently we're gonna try
to let you guys know what we're gonna be
playing
sophal you guys can play it along with
us maybe leave some comments follow
along kind of share your experiences
with the game etc etc leave that in the
comments below if you're interested and
that about does it for this week thank
you John Luke thanks see you guys
you
[Music]